there is a segment of the population  that will swallow taught media talking  points right they just swallow it and  they regurgitate it with zero  independent thought zero independent  research and they do that because they  want to take out  uh thought and conversation they don't  like and people that they don't like  so you saw with kovid with no  independent research it's the same  people that were shouting you down if  you were bringing up stats about masks  or bringing up stats about the side  effects of the vaccine that you were  seeing in your own Community or bringing  up any stats that they didn't like you  suddenly became the target they chewed  up and swallowed fauci's whatever  and regurgitated it and now they will  chew up and swallow a mainstream media  story about Tate because they don't like  the message that he's saying they don't  like his message